welcome back head good to see you again
man thank you for having me back
well I'm happy you're back but I'm not
happy that there was a motivation to
bring you back based on the violence you
know the violence that is going on
between the cartels and it was the
Mormons and then there was we were just
talking about this other person that got
shot because they ran what explain it
again they were ran a cartel roadblock
yeah basically in Tamaulipas a lot of
the cartel groups actually make they
build their roadblocks in the on the
south state and local roads and
according to what I've heard from some
of the people that I know they're this
family ran one of those roadblocks they
didn't know if it was cops or not and
they apparently decided to run the
roadblock and they cartel guys shot them
what should someone do if they encounter
a cartel roadblock slow down I mean if
if anything I would probably avoid
traveling through those areas that's the
number one widens usually you know and
I've actually gone through some of those
myself really yeah and it's it's all
about they're all there they're looking
out for the four rivals moving through
their territory they're looking for
government personnel maybe spying on
them and usually didn't usually they'll
just shake you down for some money and
they'll let you go on your way unless
you have a 4x4 truck that can use for
their you know their own purposes which
is what they might take your truck yeah
the specifically intimate liepa's 4x4
trucks are a commodity for them they use
them for their ongoing turf war all
right especially someone else's they
don't mind getting shot up yeah I mean
most of the trucks that you see eight
went that are arm up armored or they
have the rifles on top are usually
stolen vehicles all of them are sold in
vehicles and a lot of them are you know
Americans crossing into Mexico some
other Americans crossing into Mexico and
just getting trucks stolen Jesus is that
that's a real common thing it's it's
it's starting to be pretty common I
recently saw a case of an apparent
abduction in in in Tamaulipas
you see the video and
and in the cartel guys come out of the
car they grab the the the owner of a
pickup truck they get him out the car
they take his cell phone leave it on the
sidewalk because they're they're aware
of all the SOS technology and they take
him inside inside of another car and
they take the truck and you thought he
would think you know it's it's because
he did something or he's involved in
something they let him go a few blocks
later and just took the truck it was all
about the truck Wow
yeah it's resources you know they're
just acquiring resources for their for
the war basically nice of them to let
him go nice of them to let him go
you know it's not always the case it was
a case but it's pretty yeah I think most
people in America are just now waking up
to the chaos that's going on down there
I think that the Mormon assassination
was a real wake-up call but I think
people are paying much more attention
now
I mean we've we talked about this was
last time you were on it was like five
months yes a lot of the stuff we talked
about those five months ago kind of
that's how things progressed we actually
did mention the Mormon community on
there which was kind of eerie yeah and
we talked about the possible designation
of cartels as terrorist attack terror
groups yeah you you had an interesting
take on that so Trump was saying that
they were gonna designate them as
terrorist groups and that they were
gonna have military action against them
yeah and then there was some sort of
negotiation with the President of Mexico
what do you think went down there so I
mean this is just you know from what I
see and from how things traditionally
happened down there
Mexico's currently has a current
currently a leftist president now there
he's ready to the left so much to the
left that he he recently gave ever
Morales a deposed leftist president of
Bolivia asylum in the country and
there's been a lot of you know pro-left
political stuff going on in Mexico
basically as soon as the designation
threat by the u.s. came down there was
some sort of negotiation and a lot of
things happened after
after some US officials went down there
and talked to the government among them
Evo Morales is out he's he went to Cuba
apparently and then went to Argentina so
he's not gonna stay in Mexico hmm
former head of public security under the
Calderon administration which is two
administrations past the president
Calderon is the one that started the
drug war he was arrested for cartel
involvement and basically for seeing
money from the cartels I saw that yeah
he was going through his immigration
process and he was actually asking for
full citizenship and they got him on
lying through the authority of the
immigration authorities he said that
he'd never received money from the
cartels and apparently he did a lot of
it right so all these things happen
after after they walked back the threat
of designating cartels as a terrorist
organization so there has been some
action so it must have made some
negotiation where Trump had said listen
we're gonna do this and he's saying hold
up let's was talk yeah I mean a main
thing is
one of the things that this current
president unrest manoa lopez obrador ran
on was creating a national police force
right a national guard is what he calls
it which had already kind of been done
before but you know change the name
change the uniform change the packaging
and it's a new thing right he wanted he
wanted the army out of the drug war
because the casualties were mounting on
both sides and he said it wasn't a
military shouldn't be a military
operation and he ran in a platform that
was called a vassals noble lassos which
means hugs not bullets right so pastries
is crushed amnesty for the cartels was
basically kind of the main theme of that
so we got into power the first thing he
did militarized police forces and create
a national garden and dissol and try to
dissolve the federal police and most of
that National Guard force was designated
to border patrol duties on the Mexican
side so some of them went to the south
of the border
I saw the southern Mexican border and
some of them went to the northern
Mexican were basically
to stem the whole illegal immigration
crisis with the caravans that's what
kind of happened and it was a kind of a
collaboration between the US and the
Mexican government so that was one of
the key points of collaboration that
they had and when this whole designation
thing went up that was kind of like a
bargaining chip that the Mexican
government had with the US and the rest
of the things that kind of transpired
afterwards you know it's pretty
interesting how a lot of things happened
after that meeting down there and how
they walked back the terrorist
designation so the terroristic terrorist
designation would mean that Trump would
have some sort of incentive to invade
Mexico it would it would it would open
up the possibility for military direct
military action against rikes strikes
without permission of the the nation
that has strikes we're going to take
place also targeting finances or
anything related to cartel activities
would be targeted we have where do the
cartels keep their cash well it's it's
it's a it's right now it's a myriad of
things they diversified long ago so it's
not like they're keeping buried cash in
a containment container somewhere in the
in the jungle like Escobar you to do
right right they're still finding some
some like rotted cash from the 80s
they're putting their money in
cryptocurrency that really yeah they're
diversifying their other their
investments in actual companies like
legit companies so they clean their
money that way real estate hotels
property on the US side so they're also
investing on the US side of the border
as well so you know money's it's not you
know it's not under the mattress or you
know giant stacks of cash in the room so
what what kind of banks do business with
the cartels how do they negotiate that
I'm not gonna say names but there's been
a few cases of pretty large banks that
have been involved in money laundering
for the cartels recently and people can
look that up easily but you would think
you would have a designate cartel you
would have cartels designated as
terrorists so now they're banks involved
in funding terrorism
so that would change things that's you
know there's a lot of things that would
happen
you know some some of these consequence
designating was a terrorist and sent
drones down there things that they kind
of don't talk about is that if a
terrorist designation does happen
most people seeking asylum in the u.s.
from Mexico now have the claim of
running from terrorists in Mexico so now
they can claim that as far as a you know
asylum seeking people can claim that now
it's a different thing you know that the
main argument that a lot of people say
is that cartels aren't can't be
considered a terrorist terrorist group
because they don't have political
aspirations the problem with that theory
is that we have a lot of political
killings by cartels in Mexico where they
shoot the candidate of one side of the
political spectrum because it's not good
for them so they influence politics they
also pay off a lot of politicians down
there and they also examples of the new
generation cartel from Wall Ihara
giving out Christmas gifts or groceries
to the poor basically doing hearts and
minds type tactics in the area are clear
political movements yeah so you know how
does it turn why is terrorism have to be
connected to politics well that's that's
in classical the classical definition of
that is of a terrorist group that's what
they're basing it on I think the cartels
and narco-terrorism is a thing in and of
itself it's a new phenomenon it should
be terrorism should be reclassified to
include it I think you know most people
that live through that type of situation
in that type of and in that diaper area
in the country they're facing some of
these cartel threats that have fled it
we'll call it what it is yeah terrorism
terrorism they're terrified yeah I mean
that's literally I mean who's more
terrifying than the cartels yeah so
what's going on with the Mormons now is
are they moving out of there now are
they gonna go back to Utah just take one
wife okay that's what it all started out
with right yeah well the fundamentalist
group and they they went down there and
kind of proceeded with their because
customs I'm in contact with with a few
of the members of that family and you
know cut
I was in contact before but when I went
on here they kind of like one of them
reached out hmm what's going on what's
up what do we need to do yeah and then
you know it was like a friendly hello
from them from past interactions and
then this happened and you know I kind
of advised a little bit but that's you
know it's it's a mess a lot of a lot of
they're leaving the communities down
there there's a lot of them down there a
lot of communities in Sonora
kalila and you know that leaving is
leaving the area it's just too dangerous
yeah it only makes sense I mean they
just don't have the arms they don't have
the tactics and power and and they're
also in the middle of one of the most
important regions in Mexico right now
for a lot of reasons main thing there's
two things that are really really kind
of happening in that region one the
traffic the trafficking of fentanyl and
heroin and all these drugs through one
of the main drug routes up into the u.s.
and there's a few factions fighting over
that region los Salazar which are a
small card self action that has
allegiances to Sinaloa cartel and the
linea cartel which is historically been
in control of Ciudad Juarez so they're
both kind of buying for control of the
area a few hours before the the massacre
actually took place there were a bunch
of firefights between these two factions
in the area so one of the main theories
is that these the this group of Mormons
basically were case of mistaken identity
kind of driving into some of the areas
where they're being protected by some of
these people it's one theory right the
other thing that people kind of need to
think about is that the largest my noble
my noble deposits of lithium on the
planet right now are a few hours away
from where that massacre took place
really yes and that is you know not
conspiracy theory or theorizing here but
it's a pretty important thing in that
region and there's a lot of interest in
that space and control for that space
and they're not mining it currently
there's a bunch of projects in play
right now
so they've identified the deposits yeah
you know people can look up the numbers
but it's it's the largest my novel
deposit of lithium on the planet well
and there was some sort of deal in the
past where a Canadian mining agency was
going to have rights to it and the
mining agency was bought by the Chinese
company so again after that Massacre a
lot of things happened a lot of the
negotiations happened that problem that
deal was one of the things that got
killed after that situation Oh No
all right so it's it's it's it's an
interesting area there's a lot of things
happening there that's got to put a
tremendous amount of pressure on the
cartels in some way right well
historically any sort of any sort of
mining operation usually has industry
around it which is perfect for the
cartels you know extortion protection
rackets feeding the the drug use in the
area from the workers you know that's is
there any way that you could see in the
future the cartels being extracted from
the positions of power that they're in
now I mean or is this something the
people in Mexico are gonna have to live
with forever and I guess people the
United States as well or is this
something that can be fixed you you've
you've talked about before in some of
your podcast and I listened to them a
lot great podcast thanks Gatewood great
you're on - thank you
you talk about legalization and how that
would help that definitely is part of
the solution and it is it is definitely
part of the solution legalizing some
drugs you know not all drugs are made
the same
maybe not fentanyl you know yeah but
that would help out some things there's
there's multiple things that could be
done to guide us towards a place where
things could save lives down there and a
lot of it is not gonna be able to be
done in Mexico it's gonna have to be
done up here right basically you know
when you you have to take care of the US
has to take care of the drug market up
here the illegal drug market and certain
things that have happened like
legalization of marijuana and marijuana
and some places up here have changed the
dynamics of what happens down there some
for the better some for some bad some
bad things have happened
talking to my friend John Norris who was
on here as well and comparing notes
seeing how a lot of the drug recruits
are up here the pot the illegal pot
grills are up here exactly like the ones
that I found in Baja six seven years ago
and how some of that drug money made
from those fields are staying in the
u.s. it's not being sent back so that
means you have an active growing cartel
presence in the US that is us-based
so I think that one of the the problems
that people have is perception is that
that's a Mexican problem it's a it's a
us-mexico problem you know you have
border there but the problem has two
root causes right social economic
inequality and destabilization and
corrupt government down there and a
thriving illegal drug market up here and
you know those two have to be solved to
set me in a combined way how many
members when you combine all the cartels
how many members are we talking about
that's that mean it's pretty hard to put
a number on how I will say this more
than a million I will say this they
defeated the Mexican army in Sinaloa
yeah that was bananas yeah when they
captured El Chapo son yeah and then the
army gave it back yeah like yeah you're
gonna have him back well sorry that
whole situation and it was like I
remember that was happening and I was
getting asked questions about her and it
was wife it was all of a sudden just
popped off you know basically a
supposedly official story from the
Mexican government is that they send a
special police unit to capture him right
which is completely false I think
because you don't send 35 agents to
capture one of the the heads of one of
the biggest Sinaloa cartel cells right
so it's pretty much by chance they spot
at this party people were on there they
went there all of a sudden I'll chop one
is it so you think they just stumbled
into him there's a I posted a video on
my
feed of the capture of this Chapel son
you can see it and you can see the
surprise and really how the agents are
kind of uncomfortable or are fearful of
what they just stumbling on imagine US
agents stumbling on one of the America's
Most Wanted individuals up here they're
gonna put them on the ground I'm gonna
handcuff it mm-hmm
and the video you can see that they
point their rifles at him and he calmly
takes out his gun and hands it to
somebody inside of the inside of the
house he was in and walks out and kind
of tries to negotiate with the people
outside the federal agents are trying to
arrest him and you can see that the
agents are like oh what did we stumble
in on Wow all right so that happened
they grabbed them they reported back to
Mexico they captured him they started to
announce the capture and his brother his
half-brother Archibald Oh basically
called in all of the reinforcements from
all surrounding towns and regions in
Sinaloa and it was flooded with a bunch
of armed cartel guys all of us you know
it was wasn't there video of the
government people in the cartel people
talking yeah there's all that there's
it's on my feed yeah you can see it if
you want it's a it's basically a an army
unit that was being sent to reinforce
security in Culiacan being surrounded by
cartel members yeah is this it right
here yeah that's it obviously the guys
running around with a vest and wearing
skinny jeans or some of these you know
oil cartel members and they just talk it
through I mean they're outnumbered and
also there was there's talk about
there's a there's a specific immunity
out there and seen in law where all the
army families members live and they were
apparently being held hostage by cartel
guys as a bargain bargaining chip so all
these guys we're seeing here they
dressed in civilian clothes with the
vest those are all cartel guys those are
real cartel guys Jesus Christ and that
those shaking hands with everybody well
you know hey what's up call me I mean
they again we go back into the hole what
what is
the fight they have in them right mmm
Sinaloa cartel was basically surrounding
some of their communities and Helen
holding their family members hostage so
that went out over the radio so as an
army remember going in to fight the
cartel so you know what I'm out of this
fight yeah so they raised their hands so
then they release the hostages everybody
backed out yeah I mean there's they
defeated the Mexican government
basically anything that went up against
you know it surrounded the city usually
you'll see classic classic Mexican
cartel activity they close off the
streets going into the city by burning
semis and trailers and stuff like that
so you would see all these burning semi
trailers in the region so if you want to
move in you can't and if you want to use
your helicopters the cartels have entire
craft capabilities so they broke out a
bunch of people from the prison just
taking advantage of the whole chaos you
can see there's a few other videos
whether there's a armored trucks with 50
cals and ma Douce is on the back of them
just moving around the city there's no
way there's no way you can this is a
breakout state prison you know took
advantage of the whole chaos and just
you know let's just let's let's break
some of our friends out all right it's
just pure chaos eventually they let that
the government decided to let him go
that's the the official story but
according to the people there
there was no government saying let him
go there was like the guys holding him
said you know what it's not worth it
yeah that's one of the the technicals as
they call him up here yeah dump trucks
the armor plate the sides and put
somebody else I'm a Giunta person living
there what else is this that's what I'm
trying to picture yeah what life is like
for the civilians and most of these
videos are all done now by civilians so
yeah there's a certain normal we'll see
in some of these cases especially in
Encino law it's part of its it's part of
the culture there and as far as sides go
you know hey the Army's coming to save
us that's not usually what's you keep
some people and some of these
communities think you know because the
cartels are
those are the guys in charge so sinaloa
always been like that like how long
Sinaloa has traditionally being been a
cradle for like the origins of some of
the hot some of the more successful
cartel heads right isn't that where
Julio Cesar Chavez is from yeah yes yeah
and you know a lot lots of lots of
anybody that anybody in law has some
sort of relationship to the cartels
because they're part of culture there no
way getting around it had a surreal
experience once when I went there I did
a class out there and the was running
around this bumpy road and then all of a
sudden just flat beautiful road oh yeah
this is the cartel part of the road that
they build it's like okay so it's like
certainly the mob in Vegas and like the
50 gets exact exactly but it's now and
way more hardcore way more hardcore yeah
some of their grave they have a
happiness little Maya is called as is
the narco Cemetery they have and it's
basically luxury condos they look like I
mean I went there I thought it was a
church and it turned out to be a tomb
Wow all right so the the opulence and
the money or it's just overt you know
and and how they move around they roll
around in vehicles with guns and nobody
does anything because they own the city
what can be what are they planning on
doing it was anybody have any plans or
is it just they're just accepting this
well you know you you you get a lot of
rhetoric about collaboration yeah that's
that's hard Unadilla maya all of those
are graves some of them have CCTV video
inside air conditioning you know alarms
there's grave those are grave sites and
the cartel guys heads go there on the
day of the dead have music live bands to
throw a case in through the air nobody
does anything Wow Jesus Christ that's
crazy
yeah I mean the opulence is mate I mean
just seeing it you know it's like having
several Escobar's in one place you know
it's not you know it's like a lot of car
a lot of cartels ahead
are from that region and a lot of their
kids grew up in that and you know the
opulence is amazing [ __ ] like is this
gonna grow I think it is it's good I
mean I don't think it is it is growing
you know again going back to my friend
John Norris and having seeing his
experiences up here finding all these
illegal drug rows in public lands it's
growing it's growing over here - yeah so
roots yeah so I think the thing that a
lot of people have to think about a lot
of these cartel guys had their kids up
here so they made their money down there
and they sent their wives up here and a
lot of these kids that were born in the
late 80s Early 90s coming with age up
here with that cartel pedigree so and
they're US citizens u.s. passport so
you're gonna you're gonna see some sort
of shift and you know they're coming of
age they'll get experience you get you
know a handoff of reins I'm the older
generation to your new generation you're
gonna see definitely it's definitely
growing
it seems so crazy to watch because it
seems like it's not discussed nearly
enough and it it seems like if it keeps
getting stronger like what we saw with
El Chapo son being released what it
what's to stop it from taking over
Mexico entirely well I mean you would
have people arguing that it already has
in different ways so I think another
thing that people gonna have to kind of
figure out and realize is that there's
factions in Mexicans in the Mexican
government so you will see a federal
government that apparently is being paid
off by a very specific large cartel
group and then you'll see state
governments that are a different
political party influenced paying off by
other cartel event groups so you'll see
you know military units moving on the
town and the state police blocking their
way to get in there because they play
for different teams right whoa you know
there's a there's a lot of talk right
now about Felipe calderón's tenure and
how his head of security of Public
Safety was on the payroll of the Sinaloa
cartel which actually came out during El
Chapo's trial
so now you're talking about basically a
federal police force that was on don't
Apple aside so he had free rein to grow
and do whatever he had to do in that
region with the support of the federal
government in a way so that technically
you know who's in control of some
regions and and realistically some
regions of Mexico are completely cartel
control now we discussed this on the
last podcast but let's give people a
little just a recap of this just so
people can understand your position when
you first started working on for the
with the the Mexican government with
this it wasn't like it is now it was so
well you give everybody just a rundown
of how it went down so I went to I went
to work for her state government down in
Mexico in Baja specifically and this was
and this was 2004 right right before the
start of the official start of the kick
off of the drug war as take off the kick
off but there was you know that the
official start was when Felipe Calderon
came into office said you know what
gloves off gonna go after the organized
crime right we're gonna send the
military into into this onto the streets
and they're gonna head up spearhead
operations against the cartels but
before that things were happening still
you know Sinaloa cartel was growing
there was a rift between the Sinaloa
cartel and Tijuana cartel and
fragmentation cartel heads were being
killed and one cartel 203 all this
fragmentation and then you know they
basically militarized the war on drugs
with Calderon came in militarized war on
drugs immediately you start seeing that
drug drug enforcement efforts were being
put towards a single or a group of
cartel groups but not the month but not
a major one like Sinaloa cartel so you
start seeing how they were basically
taking sides they were breaking up the
competition that's what you would gather
from the making it look like progress
yeah and oh and also old chapel has been
built up into this mythical figure aqui
was the head of the Sinaloa cartel he's
the main guy and that's not true at all
he was an operator for the Sinaloa
cartel but not the main operator you
know there's different theories and and
and about who is actually who was
actually in charge or the brain it's
behind the whole operation
when you say Sinaloa cartel it's not one
group it's several it's a federation of
several criminal groups enterprises
uniting and working in conjunction to
put drugs into the into the United
States well one of the things they did
was put drugs into United States you do
a lot of things but that's one of the
things they do so you know certain
people sure there's a lot of people out
there that theorized that mile sambata
which is El Chapo's compadre who's still
out there is the actual head of the
Sinaloa cartel and has been since a
start but you see how some of these
people become celebrities and as soon as
somebody becomes a celebrity like el
chapo who escaped from custody a few
times you know under you know pretty
interesting situated in the situations
now the government has a celebrity that
can go after so they can point at that
guy and that guy's a bad guy right so
that you saw a lot of that a lot of
theatrics around him as far as him being
the head of whatever you know group or
operation was but at the same time you
started seeing you know the DEA and and
the in the US government been decorating
and putting all these awards on a guy
like Luna who was the guy that got
arrested recently who was head of
security down in Mexico and now all of a
sudden he's no no he's not you know he
was recognized by the US government as
being a player for the good guys and now
he's arrested so you start seeing all
these you know different interests
different political political kind of
movements around the drug war and what
that turned into and you know you know
what you don't know what they think
right each and each also each US
administration has changed the way they
do things and when it comes to the drug
war and also benefits certain groups
down there so you know who knows
realistic [ __ ] yeah it's just you know I
went to Chichen itzá I think in
Shh mm - maybe 2003 somewhere around the
that time and there was no concern yeah
yeah it's a different time
yeah that's but that's 16 17 years ago
that's so recent in terms of like human
history yeah that a region changes so
radically so quickly well it's it's it
there's a lot of things happening you
know there's a lot of interest China has
a lot of interest in Mexico
and you go back and you see something
like this you see things like the the
whole house um armed groups started
popping up in Mexico in the Michoacan
area fighting back against the cartels
the the whole it was like series like a
documentary on them the the outlaw
defense as they would they would call
basically like vigilante groups and then
you later on you realize that they were
all fighting for basically protecting or
kink or working around security for
illegal Chinese or Myer mining in the
area whoa yeah it's all it was all about
Chinese ore mining iron ore mining
illegal Chinese or mine so the Chinese
or miners they just made a deal yeah and
then you know that's we can get in on it
so let's arm all these guys and we're
protecting our communities but they're
oh it was a lot of well not not all of
them but a lot of there was a lot of
shady stuff going on in the region and
when it comes to that now you see things
like that stuff that's going on in
Sonora and there's a lot of lithium
there that's pretty valuable thing you
know Sonora is a place that a lot of
hunters go yeah Sonora has these big
hunting ranches and it's like it's
famous for giant mule deer yeah yeah
yeah it's a I've been up out there
hunting myself and it's a it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful part of
Mexico but that seems like a sketchy
spot - but it's venturing its - it's
perfect because it it's perfect with
them because of rule so there's nobody
around but if you were like a guy from
Texas want to drive your truck down
there it's a little hunting I mean not
my recommendation is this if you have a
4x4 don't
take it down there take a [ __ ] you go
we do have the largest population of
American citizens living outside of the
country in Mexico for some reason so
really yeah
in all throughout Mexico yeah I mean all
throughout Mexico this one down there
well a lot of people like Cabo people
love Mexican food yeah yeah yeah there's
there's there's there's a certain
chaotic freedom in Mexico which out you
know I've cut being some a child of
Mexico and then moving up here and
seeing you guys talk about freedom not
that but but there's there's I get the I
get the draw you know and some of these
communities down there pretty safe but
some are you know they're safe until
they're not safe and safe until they
until they all of a sudden you're in the
middle of a someplace that it's gonna be
disputed which is I think is something a
long one is that what happened to some
of these Mormon communities down there
hmm
you know you're on your you're in the
middle of your community and your
movements are in the middle of our route
could you please get out of the way
what's the ceiling on this like if if
they can continue to grow I mean it's
it's really is it possible that we're
looking at a country that might be
completely run and overrun by criminal
organizations and drug sellers some
parts of it are already so what I think
is gonna happen is you'll see
escalations a clear sign or a clear
group that is like a sign of things to
come is the is a new generation cartel
the new generation cartel is a cartel
that was it used to be called los amatis
etis there was basically an armed
enforcing group that Sinaloa cartel made
to go after their main rivals isettas
which were originally members of special
Mexican special forces that said you
know what we're gonna be cartel guys
oh now in cartel enforcers now so they
whole sordid history these it was a
militarized group that was formed formed
to go after them right and their whole
kind of play was that we're gonna be
against extortion against abducting
people against the effect in the
community we're going to enforce the law
in our communities
but we're also gonna move drugs through
here right but that you know that's kind
of their thing so you see this group
started kind of rolling in the region
and right now it's pretty big it's
rivaling the Sinaloa cartel as far as
power and reach but the way they do
their things is militarized it's very
militaristic and kind of paramilitary
and it kind of reminds me a little bit
about of the like the the FARC groups in
Colombia hearts and minds they go into
the communities that community policing
in the area that he originally said you
know we were where the government wants
to fight drugs here in the region we
agree with their fight but we are also
going to fight against these guys that
are affecting community as well and they
have like groups of people they have
they have training camps no medical
militaristic trading camps where they
recruit people they take them there and
they're being trained in gorilla warfare
and shooting and apparently there's some
SF guys from the US that that advise
them so that's that's the next thing the
escalation of a simple ragtag group of
cartel guys in force in the region to an
actual cohesive paramilitary group now
trying to vie for control not just of
the of the drug routes but also have the
populace and confidence of the populace
as in them so it could turn political at
some point right it just seems like it's
the genies out of the bottle it hit I
mean it is I mean it is in a lot of ways
you know and going after it just as a
you know drug enforcement issue it's not
you know it's it's so much bigger than
that yeah it's a cultural it's an
economic you know some of these kids
I've got posted up some of these cartels
soldier kids at 12 years old
plated guns gold plated guns you know
they don't have an OP they don't have
options in their lives right it's that
or nothing
right it's either awesome life or short
Austrian poverty short awesome life yeah
a short awesome life or extreme poverty
so that's when a component to it another
component is systemic corruption as a
society from who knows when you know
it's always been a thing in Mexico
people that grew up down there you get
stopped at
red light and you're like can I pay the
fine here you know people that are from
now there will be aware of this yeah
show you the chill the paperwork you
slide that thing in there you know
that's you know that's part of the
culture that's affecting a lot of things
as well you know people don't pay
attention to the small rules so the big
rules don't matter right and just being
next to the largest drug market on the
planet you know and having money
firearms rounds going down and fentanyl
that it's being fabricated in Mexico now
and some of the Chinese fentanyl making
its way through into the u.s. kind of
filling the voids that some of the the
drug market has right now so they're
making fentanyl laced fake fentanyl
laced pills they're going to be they're
being put into US and fentanyl laced
heroin right so that's where they're
going towards now that's what you see
this epidemic up here and a lot of
things traditionally kind of focused on
pot before it was legalized in a lot of
arenas up here now is heroin and
fentanyl so it's actually kind of
accelerated the production of the more
harmful and dangerous drugs in some ways
yes I mean they had to find another you
know it was it went pot meth and now
fentanyl-laced heroin or fentanyl laced
pills see in the problem with the idea
of legalization is that if you try to be
the person who says hey folks we need to
legalize drugs here in America because
we've got this problem with the cartels
politically that suicide yeah no no one
I mean even though it's probably right
it is I think it is I think it is very
right it's one of those things that's so
counterintuitive that most people are
gonna go you're crazy you're gonna make
my kids hooked on drugs well I'll say
this I was I fought in the drug war I
literally a drug war veteran yeah and if
I had a white flag I would hand it over
to you you know it's like I that this
it's a useless fight I got to destroyed
pot fields realistically thinking about
all the effort and all the blood I'm
like yeah and it's so quick to grow back
I mean that yeah it is it is a fruitless
fight fentanyl
heroin may be different drugs fentanyl
in particulars but a lot of that
fentanyl is coming from China it's not a
Mexican thing oh yeah a lot of people
that are making or producing fentanyl in
places like Mexico are from China
setting up laboratories in Mexico so
it's a it's a Chinese Mexican us problem
as well god damn what can be done other
than the legalization what could be done
I mean how does and unless the United
States literally goes to war with the
Mexican cartels and you may have faced
talking about that I mean I'd say
designation is one I think that's a
nation should it's it's going to happen
a terrorist designation it's gonna
happen I mean again we just saw the
murder the massacre of Mexican they were
dual citizenship nine people kids women
it's not uncommon for that to happen to
Mexican nationals it's pretty uncommon
for that to happen to American nationals
down there and that woke up woke up a
bunch of people you know mm-hmm and now
we another recent murder of another
American national you know kid with his
parents down there you know people will
say but just don't go down to Mexico but
but some of these people you know live
down there and have family down there
and have communities down there it's
just ultra violent you know that people
have to wake up on this side to realize
this problem is not going to get any
better this problem is not just a
Mexican problem it's a US Mexican
problem and you know they'll get to a
point where it's gonna be you know I
think in my lifetime it's gonna be some
sort of armed intimate intervention in
Mexico at some point really
so you anticipate almost like in a civil
war I think something's gonna happen in
Mexico is going to destabilize it so
much that the u.s. won't have another
option but to put boots on the ground
probably that's I think that's that's
where we're headed the problem and again
another of the problems is that the
government is part of the problem so you
can go down there and negotiate with
this government but six years later it's
gonna be another government you got to
renegotiate with
yeah and also use you palm grease yeah
and then you put all your faith in the
military and the military gets
compromised
you put all the fate and the Mexican
Marines and then they get compromised
and now who do you have all right so
it's systemic don't tell that to trump
he'll use as an excuse we can't count on
them we're going in I I mean I wonder
where it all goes because it is
obviously growing very fast
it's obviously huge and incredibly
powerful and and it affects I mean I'm
up here now and I could see the effects
of it up here walking through LA seeing
all the needles on the ground going to
Seattle seeing the same light brown
fentanyl-laced heroin that I saw in
shanty towns down ah it's like wow so
this is where it kind of ends up oh yeah
so you said you see the effects of it
throughout so you know you you you
realize quickly as somebody from both
sides that I am you realize that there
realistically there's no border there's
kind of no border when it comes to this
problem it was brought this problem
doesn't respect a border wall right
right
submarines will go around it tunnels
will go under it drones will fly over it
and it's a it's a problem that just
keeps you know producing an effect and I
think the majority of the United States
citizens are completely unaware of the
complexity and the depth of the problem
yeah I mean it is well it's in it's also
I think most people seeing the Iran
thing right now most people know more
about that oh yeah when off going on
halfway across the world yeah
then what's going on just you know
that's what's crazy to me it's like you
know we're we're into invading countries
that are really barely affecting us that
are like a 17 hour plane flight yeah I
think I think the again I don't I don't
want to be Ed Adamas and you know
predict stuff Eddie Thomas but the fact
that we have a lot of lithium incident
is going to be a factor for a reason to
clean it up it should be it should be
it's pretty important it's a pretty
important resource yeah but if they
can't hold on the El Chapo's Sun huh
that's that's why I think us gun is
gonna have to you know put foot
something boots on the ground down there
Wow
now if you had to make a bet like if
there's a betting line in Vegas like how
many how many days or how many years
from now
weirdly be American soldiers deployed to
Mexico I'd say five years maybe whoa in
five years really I mean we we are on we
just passed this this past year has been
the most violent year in Mexico in
recorded history really and it's the
first year of administration of this new
president right who's been trying to
hugs hugs how to not not bullets ever a
saloon or molasses you know this instead
of that
it's been his first year and you know
give him a chance he's he's doing
whatever he's only the most violent year
in history yeah cut the guy a break
exactly that's what they say but then I
go down there and I have a lot of a lot
of my friends that are still down there
people that have trained still down
there and I hear from them directly like
I have some young kids that are in the
tender media which is like a federal
police force that patrols all of Mexico
and some of the federal federal police
guys they tell me like head we're we
they said or you sign the new contract
to be the water thing yes or no and
lower your pay and all your all of the
stuff that all your benefits will be
gone or you just stay on here and limbo
and just stay at the base and a lot of
them are staying at the base so it's
nothing nothing's nothing's nothing's
being done well I imagine that if it
seems overwhelming and it seems helpless
and it seems like the cartels are just
taking over and they're making a
shitload of money and you're not making
any money I mean that that is the real
crazy thing about right there if the the
government is asking people in this sort
of already compromised situation
environment asking them to work for a
small amount of money to go after people
that are making a tremendous amount of
money yeah and you're gonna be a war
with these people these people they're
basically your neighbors yeah and also
you go there with a federal uniform but
for another federal government you go
into a community where you the federal
government doesn't do anything for them
right the church is made by the cartels
cartel made the road Christmas was
brought brought to you by the cartels
you know they they're the good guys so
these guys come in here like with you
guys like what are they they work we're
not gonna so that's you know it's it's
it's it's it is it's it's a mess it's a
mess
Wow but could boots on the ground
actually fix anything
I mean I'm not a I'm not a I'm not a
military expert but there has to be some
sort of outside force that is completely
uncompromised by cartel money and
influence how long before they
compromise those people well when you
put the Marines on the border a few of
them got picked up on smuggling people
from the border so yeah that's what I'm
saying it's it's and it's also it's a
different war field because a lot of you
know a lot of our war fighters and law
enforcement are have some sort blood
ties to Mexico mmm of course and not
only down I was just watching some video
where there was this guy who is a u.s.
veteran been deployed overseas fought
for this country and his mom was getting
deported and he said he felt betrayed
like here he is in America is his mother
brought him over here had him over here
he's a US citizen and they're deporting
his mom as if his mom was a danger or
the problem there's a community of Army
marine and several veterans that are
deported veterans that live in in place
like Tijuana that's [ __ ] crazy that
is [ __ ] crazy you all right for the
country man you get a DUI in here but
how nuts is that it is pretty nuts it's
[ __ ] ridiculous fight for this
country youyou literally risk your life
and there's [ __ ] out there that
haven't done a goddamn thing been
mooching off the system forever and
their citizens and you're not yeah I
mean my perspective in my life
life path you know when I came up here I
want it I want to earn it right I don't
know I came up here motivated want to do
a difference work and apparently you
know I've had I have had some you know
static in my in my endeavors my kid was
born in the US and parented her mom's
American right when I went to to the
hospital to pay for the the insurance
part of it the laughs that means that
you shouldn't pay any of this you're
Mexican you just can claim benefits
alright that that was in California so
that was like oh but I can afford it no
you just ways around this
no and that's when I knew you know
there's America there's California
America all right
California America is different yeah
California America is very different
it's a subtle blend I mean there's
there's ways around stuff you know
there's free stuff you know get it it's
weird yeah again I travel across the
country just get to experience different
parts of the u.s. I spent New Year's in
Kentucky and that's pretty interesting
huh oh it's good I mean I like it you
know maybe it's like a it's like a white
Mexico is it yeah how so
people were shooting guns into the air
and on Year's Eve that's pretty Mexican
they do that indexes to oh well you know
again you know I don't know it's it's
it's not good some lady got shot oh it's
completely was standing in her driveway
grandma with her family and the bullet
fell out of the sky and hit her in the
chest yeah when we when you really would
come we would park underneath the
bridges and in Baja to not get you know
there's firearms are legal in Mexico and
then you know racing right tracer rounds
it's going oh my god I like tracer
rounds okay you know it's it's it's
again Mexico is a weird place you know
it's why I call it the upside down you
know you know there's there's there's a
chaotic freedom to Mexico which I get I
mean I love my I love Mexico as a
country as a culture I don't like the
government though
the government is just you know at all
levels it's just you know it's not a
good well it seems like it's always been
that way I'm reading this book about Kit
Carson and the Old West and when the
United States
you know conquered parts of California
and and took over parts of California
and in the West from Mexico and it was
crazy back then yeah yeah and they were
they were talking about the the chaos in
in the Mexican government and the
Mexican military back then in the 1800s
yeah yeah I mean so so people kind of
figured realized if you want to be an
officer in the in the Mexican army you
have to go through War College and
there's different ways to go about it
but there's a lot of hereditary stuff
going on already Terry okay my dad was a
general okay yeah there's a lot of that
going on also the army down there has a
monopoly over selling guns it's only one
gun store in all of Mexico and it's run
by the army
what yep one gun story no man all Mexico
and is run by the army and you have to
fly to Mexico City to to get a license
and to procure a firearm so if you live
in the Yucatan you have to fly them and
get a fly to Mexico City to get a gun
which makes which basically makes the
only options buying a gun on the black
market or flying over there and
expending all this money so there's a
now it's a class so only only people
that can afford the plane ticket and to
do all this process are the ones that
can have guns so it's a that's class you
know the class is involved in there as
well what kind of rights do you have
with guns versus the United States
Second Amendment is it somewhere so the
Constitution Mexican Constitution allows
for guns for self-defense but a lot of
amendments and a lot of corrupt
governments down there said you mean
maybe you're not a good idea to have
this here so progressively throughout
New Mexican region Mexican history it's
become more and more strict all right
certain rounds aren't allowed certain
calibers aren't allowed and this just
plainly the sale of firearms in all of
Mexico is just relegated to a single gun
store in Mexico City so you can't carry
them without without a permit and to get
a permit you have to know
knows the Presidente or a general
something but what about all those
gentlemen we saw in that video just
walking in front of those government
agents with with guns why didn't they
arrest them they should have they should
have their homes like theirs yeah well
long break the only people that respect
those laws are you know law-abiding
citizens there was a case in Veracruz of
an old man a former army guy old older
gentleman his son tried to get abducted
some something like that he had this old
Mauser rifle and he shot dead one of the
guys that was chasing him is trying to
abduct him he was arrested for the the
firearm possession and the Hauser's
would leave Harvey Oswald supposedly
used on JFK yeah that's an old ass gun
well there's a lot of weird old ass
stuff down there you mean as far as the
stuff that gets handed over or just the
weird exotic firearms down there a lot
of people called Mexico the US is a
garage and likely like garages you just
find weird stuff down there from old
world war ii era pistols and explosives
to new stuff like there's a friend of
mine that works for the government down
there told me that they found a bunch of
parts for a minigun in it you know how
somewhere down there what's a minigun
it's basically a remember that go ahead
remember that Terminator 2 yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah pretty hard to get you know
one of those apparently there's one out
there somewhere on a vehicle of some
sort well Jesus it's basically a
obliterated everything well we talked
about the IDI holder fast and furious
deal last time that you were here and
that to me still is one of the most
bizarre cases in in the history of an
undercover operation that doesn't make
any sense at all yeah they sold guns
like literally sold working guns to a
specific cartel down there to tried it
was so they could track them or I
remember what kind of [ __ ] argument
that was the the the interesting part or
if you want to go into the
you know questions that they benefited a
single cartel the Sinaloa cartel that's
the that's the thing you know that's
most of the guns went to that if you had
a guess if you were a conspiracy if
there's like put on your tinfoil hat
what do you think that was all about
they would probably as a nation you were
probably one wanting to only worry about
a single threat as far as cartels and
not a lot of cartels so they empowered
one cartel yeah really I mean where that
was coming off the Patriot Act era Bush
era thing I remember vividly people
putting geiger counters in some of the
drug tunnels that we would find so they
were worried about nukes getting put
into drug tunnels at some point during
during that whole post 9/11 era so it
would make sense that if you are worried
about national security you would want
to not worry about a lot of cartels
maybe focus on one support one and just
keep us in the know do you think this
was a covert operation a sense of the
Sinaloa cartel was not aware that they
were doing this to empower them to
eliminate the competition to strengthen
one group because they just knew it was
inevitable that someone there's a lot
control there's a lot of people that are
now coming out after the whole there's a
lot of things that were said at the
Chapo trial that are that would lead
somebody to believe that there was some
sort of official support from the US
government to the Sinaloa cartel as far
as then having deals with these cartels
specifically to keep things to keep them
in the know about things happening down
there supporting them to be that be in
the position so they can keep control
over their region and basically as an
information group so they can have have
a clear eye and ear in a chaotic area
like Mexico on the bad guys side that's
what I that's why I gathered from it
Jesus Christ but that kind of it's it's
all it's almost like they feel like it's
helpless like they have to do something
like that that they have to do that
because there's no way to fix it so what
you got to do is kind of try to manage
it or move it and
directions so there's this there's all
up like every night every now and then I
post some stuff about that type of
situation and everybody goes to well the
CIA has been running drugs into the u.s.
for years and using planes it's not like
that
there is there are instances of CIA
involvement and different stuff down in
Mexico that are pretty obvious now from
the 80s and then in the 90s as far as
supporting certain groups or just trying
to keep tabs on these people but you
know I think we're coming to a point in
our history where a lot of these people
are dead a lot of these people are in
jail a lot of these people got book
deals and people are talking and I mean
it's interesting seeing some of the
stuff that it's coming out now that in
my time when I was active would have
gotten you in a hole probably somewhere
if he talked about it mmm so there's
definitely I mean I my mind was blown
when I was seeing all Chappell and
Netflix because a lot of stuff that was
going on in that Joe is fictionalized
stuff that I went through myself so I
was like this is on Netflix now how
accurate was there's some pretty good
accurate parts so there's a there's a
character in that show called so we're
talking about narcos and we're talking
about the Mexican version of narcos
right because without their zombie in
first yeah they're there's a narcos is
pretty good there's a there's a chapel
series on Netflix as well oh there is
yeah it's in Spanish
it's very popular but it's pretty
accurate there's a guy in that in the
subtitles it does there's a guy in the
show Conrado
solo is his name which would nobody
would people are trying to figure out
who that was it's basically a government
guy that had a deal with El Chapo and
they both kind of escalated in power it
turns out it was Luna right so this show
was showing him the character El Sol
which depicts Luna as a corrupt
politician that was working security was
working both sides and all of a sudden
you know recently a few months a few
weeks back they arrested the guy so the
show was kind of predicted
do you think that the show had anything
to do with him being arrested I mean it
probably put I put the idea and the
zeitgeist of people to ask questions you
know yeah that's weird that shows
actually do do that like saving
surviving r.kelly that's what got him
arrested I mean everybody knew he not
people I'm like [ __ ] 20 years ago he's
peeing on little kids yeah now it gives
people like a good
it's interesting you see you see
fictionalized forms up stuff that
happened down there the narcos show as
well is another thing you know see
fictionalized things mmm how some of
these powerful cartel groups kind of
originated themselves in fiction and now
that is in the public kind of domain as
far as collective knowledge so people
start asking questions and some of these
things
parent lis people in power also ask
questions as well Jesus Christ it's just
it's so strange how popular it's become
you know and it's such a popular focal
point of fiction as well and in fashion
you know chapels picture with uh Sean
Penn yeah the shirt was fire everybody
wanted that shirt you know that Conor
McGregor like wore something to mimic it
when on purpose with a pro in the press
conference for Rafael dos Anjos did you
know that yeah her stood he stood in the
same stance like look at him look at him
I mean he's doing it on purpose yeah
it's like a subtle nod to El Chapo yeah
I mean he's a chaplet achieved legendary
status now or sure
now his kid that was freed by the the
the cartel down there he was wearing a
scalpel REO which is like you could I
don't know if you can see it in there
it's an interesting just big piece of a
cultural thing from Mexico what is going
on in this video that was just handed
the gun over it what his personal gun
over to one of his bodyguard said was
not even these guys don't even care
about him they had a head camera thing
and they're putting everybody out there
and personally I would put everybody in
zip ties and on the ground personally so
these guys all have guns drawn and
there's people inside with guns drawn at
them and they realize they realize who
they have
so they're like should we forcefully put
him in cuffs are we not so how do you
know that they're realizing this right
is because of the language they're
saying I've went through a lot of the
same training that they went through and
I did a lot of this type of stuff and
all of them would have been in zip ties
on the ground this girl went reached out
and grabbed their guns and put their
guns down compose there's there's fear
in these people they realize that they
messed up oh Jesus
right so that's what you know people
question and there are these streaming
this video live that they they have that
in their head cam a head cam and they're
streaming it not well it's not you know
that they have cording recording it and
it gets sent back to the command post so
when he was moving around he had one of
these on this is a SCAP Ilario
it's called it's like a religious
catholic iconography thing
what is yours what is it this is a santa
marta one right it's like a holy death
effigy so he had that on he had his was
a Santoni Niall at Tojo which is like a
Catholic to say yeah Christ
baby st. they have as soon as that
picture of him went on online they were
sold out all throughout seeing law
everybody was wearing that they have to
work you know they work it was work
cousin Frank got him Freya's areas
that's a that's a scapular do something
you handsome guy yeah that's an also an
interesting cultural thing the occult
part of it were that that's Anthony you
know that torch a shrine is right now
it's probably most popular shrines in
Mexico or that one because they work and
then you go to the holy death shrines
down there as well and you see how how
both sides both Mexican government
forces and the cartel they they both
been irate kind of the same Saints so
with that again that's a weird kind of a
thing they share that faith what does
that picture of his truck down there
Jamie you have some wacky truck no just
two regular truck
that's his yeah that's one of those
little bullets he gave out cars on
Christmas he as a like he did this
pointy - any like townspeople or how
many cars do you get out I have no
like a lot of them there's pictures of
the El Chapo's Sun gives out cars on
Christmas and there's a bunch of cars
there you know again who who are you
like who are you gonna go towards and of
course government you know are you don't
give me anything yeah they like you said
hearts and minds they're really yeah
Hines and and and you know they they pay
for a college education so there's a
whole generation of lawyers a whole
generation of doctors they pay for
immigration procedures so hey you want
to you know yeah I'll pay for your
immigration but you know I'm gonna call
in some favors later on okay Wow so
that's you know that's that's how that's
how you grow it's full-on mafia [ __ ]
yeah I mean they learned one day I'll
come to you Al Capone Al Capone you know
Scarface you know all these things are
kind of venerated by them that's kind of
their cultural backing off cultural
backing they kind of look to the mob era
guys as influence or as inspiration you
see you know insane paintings of The
Godfather or Scarface in some of these
safe houses what these people are all
right and you're like okay or you see
cartel influenced series for Netflix
like there's one called la reina del
sewer
which is about a female cartel head and
the lady that stars in that show was the
one that took Sean Penn down there de
miel Chapel because no Chapel was a fan
of that show really that's how it got
going when they finally caught up to him
he had the whole series on DVDs that is
pretty humanized another oh my god that
that whole scene with Sean Penn going
down there and writing a story for
Rolling Stone was uber bizarre yeah well
if they get the the terrorist
designation he basically went down there
to meet with a terrorist what happens to
him then is it all retroactive I don't
know I don't know but they he helped get
him arrested in a sense right you
basically that whole commotion put eyes
on
on the movements of El Chapo by the
Mexican government
why would hell chapo agree to do
something like that he was a fan of the
show that seems so crazy though doesn't
it seem crazy that he was willing to
take that kind of a risk and take a
photo with Sean Penn and that that
actress well I was what's her name again
okay got it got the cut that cuts to you
yeah right there yeah chapo is probably
banging that right
a fighter yes there's rumors there's
rumors of a meeting that's about it I
don't know anything else
yeah uh-huh yes I don't say yeah that's
just the whole thing with Sean Penn
smiling hey here's my friend the
murderer I mean I get the eye I mean
I've heard some of the stuff Sean Penn
said about you know Chavez in Venezuela
and stuff like that oh he's Pro Chavez
and Suffolk gonna have people friends of
mine that live in men as well under to
that regime so he's a pretty kooky guy
he has some pretty interesting ideas
about he can't possibly be that informed
I don't know I mean how you you really
have to have boots on the ground to
understand what the [ __ ] you're talking
about and you have to be there for you
know if you want to know what's going on
in Venezuela there's so many different
stories my friend Abby Martin it's been
down there multiple times and she gives
me a story that's so different than
anything that you're getting in
mainstream news and she goes there she
goes there and talks to people yeah
spends time well I have a there's a
there's a resistance group that is based
in the US that works down there and you
know they put up videos all the time of
people picking up garbage and trying to
recycle garbage to feed themselves in
some places Instagram immediately takes
all those downs right really yeah why
does Instagram take those down I have a
lot of that going on as well when I post
something completely news related about
something and then get shadow banned or
things just go down depending on what I
post up like weird things posted up a
Venezuelan people throwing rocks at this
armored vehicle and one of them
when the got run run over and I got
taken down I didn't show the part where
he got run over but just the people
protesting and how would that get taken
down they got flagged as support for a
hate group or something like that
support for a hate group by showing the
news yeah or showing a picture of cartel
and again I don't post anything graphic
on my feed because I don't want to get
banned but I'm still shadow band right
so well you showed that one by the way
edie manifesto that's how you find it
edie manifesto that's that that's Ed's
page you posted that one where you you
saw a guy getting abducted yeah by fake
cops yeah yeah and and that one get
pulled yeah it did yeah all of that all
of the recent scene a long video ones
are our fault were all pulled off the
Instagram account that's why I had to
real upload them all I just don't
understand their logic I mean look I can
understand them saying caution some of
these images and videos are sensitive
you know like with some bloody things
and things along those lines something
changed in the algorithms a year back
like when I was on your first time I was
on the show I got obviously I saw a
spike thank you by the way but all of
the pro Second Amendment pages and
people like there's a guy crispy it was
yeah yeah also you got a lot all of a
sudden all this started seeing a lot of
us are flagged
yeah his stuff got taken down yeah and
yeah I think he got a there was a photo
of him with Donald Trump that got taken
down
yeah my sense I think was Donald Trump
do you like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you people
yeah just because you don't align with
someone politically you can't take down
photos and you can't pretend that he's
posing with Hitler or something like
yeah [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's uh it's the people can report
things anonymously I think and yes and
if you hurt my feelings
there you go so if there's enough people
that flag your video and say this is
hurtful or this is they don't even look
into it they just pull it down yeah so
who do you think is doing do you think
this Mexican government is doing that do
you think it's the cartels that are
doing that page I think it's mostly
Americans that have
sensibilities that are completely beyond
my comprehension that see a gun in a
picture and they're afraid of the gun
and it is terrorism they're supporting
terrorism a group let's report that
picture or video well I could understand
how some of what you're reporting on
truthful as it may be would be
disturbing to be able to find out that
truth but you gotta let people do that I
mean I mean what does Instagram want it
I mean do they want to put parameters on
what kind of truth you're allowed to
distribute so just for people to get
some contacts I I do work for to to
magazine companies and I do do articles
so in that regard I do provide news in
in in certain ways but when I post
something on my page it's a personal
view of something I purposefully don't
go into graphic material because I don't
want to get flagged but sometimes
there's always people with a certain
affinity to when they see a gun in a
post or where they see an animal being
butchered for something like in a
picture or when they see hunting related
stuff or when they see some sort of I
remember posting up a picture of the
make Tijuana great again hats that they
were making down their red hats that
said make Tijuana great again when the
caravans went into TJ and people started
protesting caravans in TJ that got
flagged what that is so crazy
oh yeah if you want to confuse if you
want to make people angry and confused
just wear one of those hats through the
air well lady got maced in the face for
wearing one that said make Bitcoin great
again yeah some guy maced her in the
face Johana
I saw somebody walked out walking an
airport with a make hentai great again
hat
anything great again you go you can't do
it be close yeah it's too close I mean
you know the Hat you know right I have
never seen anything more divisive in
this country I mean other than like a
swastika or something like overtly
disgusting I I started my immigration
process when he got elected oh no it's
it's it's been a trip you know
how does that work like if you are
Mexican born citizen and you want to
become the United States citizen
obviously it's very difficult it so
married to an American have an American
kid that's how I went through the
process myself and you know I got a
green card the the thing is that when he
got elected everybody said you know what
maybe our time to get a green card is
gonna get be less and less so let's all
try and get one mmm so what would take
normally six months took two years
oh wow so in those two years you can't
leave the country so if you what happens
to people that are illegal over that's
what's [ __ ] up about it right it's
like there's people that came over here
illegally 20 30 years ago and they've
done no crimes they've been an integral
part of society they've had great lives
but they they can't pay taxes they can't
vote they have to live undercover
yeah I mean [ __ ] that's stupid they're
there you know the end they do provide
you know they decide they pay taxes
through other other sales tax buying
things but they're not paying taxes
they're not kept in but if you made them
citizens you would make money yeah well
it's not a popular view it's a stupid
view yeah it's it's stupid that we have
these people and they're permanent
illegals yeah and they will be here
until they die illegally and we know
they're here like how about work with
what you've got look you've already do
you doing your best to stop the border
traffic great fantastic but listen let's
just forget about the past
these people are here they're here and
they're a part of our community like how
you how are you gonna deny them
citizenship to the day they die and
they're still here well legal
immigration it's like I went through is
hard enough you gotta find some American
lady that's just difficult yeah I did
and you know but it was a hard process
it's uh it's it's it's a difficult
process and you speak fluent English yes
that's another thing I saw people in the
line with me you know that did not speak
a lick of English but they were from a
country that had a
like Holland or some [ __ ] from has a
vote it's hard for Canadians man I have
friends from Canada that have come over
here to try to become citizens it's a
[ __ ] grind yeah and and and don't get
me wrong I love this country a bit I'm
new here and I like what I see I don't
like where it's going in some places
what don't you like I don't like the I
mean I left my country because I
couldn't defend myself from the bad
people out there whose second amendment
second amendment yeah it's a beautiful
thing you have no idea how beautiful
that thing is till you don't have an
option to have it that's one thing I
like to do opportunities this country
provides I've had a lot of opportunities
I would never get anywhere else
I like the UK actually work and work
you're the work you put in matters here
I like like I was segmented and
different you go to Tennessee and you
meet people out there and they're great
people you know there's some you know
people have preconceived notions of what
some part of the countries are but I've
loved it and then you go to California
and you meet people that are on the same
boat as I was and they're forgot
completely what Mexico is and they're
completely recognized Americanized and
they're completely against you as a new
a new person here really yeah so you
find that really like Americanized
Mexicans or like second third generation
Mexicans the worst enemy of a Mexican is
another Mexican that's a classic but
that's a classic that's a classic
Mexican saying and it's true well that
that's a classic Mexican saying but
really most of the negativity negativity
I got from being on your show the first
time was from Latinos specifically
Mexican Latinos what was the negativity
what was their criticism when I talked
about how Mexicans protested the
caravans going through Tijuana and
wrecking their city that was viewed as
extreme to the right or conservative
viewpoint apparently yeah but that was a
fact but the apparently facts don't
matter oh that's so silly but that's
people that's that's a good that's a
good example of people that are not
there yeah out of talking about it
you're not saying you didn't make a
value judgment saying that those people
coming through were protested by
Mexicans need to go back
were [ __ ] rice paddy they come from
you didn't say any of that so so this is
what I saw when I when I talked about it
looks like experience that I wasn't I
was in TJ for a while when that was
happening
firing caravan goes through obviously a
lot of those guys were gang members a
lot of them were not all of them a lot
of them more covered in tattoos it's
pretty hot outside wearing all of our
important hoodies cameras came by the
females and the children were being put
in front parading from the media to
anybody was there you could see the
circus I was going on hmm
and then a lot of the a lot of the camp
encampments they would they would you
know litter the encampments with needles
on the outside one of them was next to a
school they've had to be closed down a
niece of mine had a kid in there and the
school had to be closed down because it
was next to one of these encampments
they would protest and close down lanes
most people that live in TJ some of them
are Americans and they commute so that's
affecting their livelihood people that
work on terrorism and TJ white book hood
went down so the fact that these people
came and disrupted all that whole thing
and then you would see these Californian
you know hippie Americans guys come down
there and do puppet shows for these
people and hand over a donations in the
form of canned food blankets uh stuff
like that and then you would see these
guys go to the back door and sell all
that stuff in the back and just get
money for whatever they were gonna use
the money for we would laugh at it but
it also you know it's pretty
disheartening having that point of view
online because I started posting some of
this stuff online for people this is
what's happening and that was like no no
no you're going against the earth now
the narrative yeah the narrative and the
and the people that are talking about
you going against a narrative have
really no idea they don't care about the
truth that's what's crazy the absolute
is thing so if you're against it if
you're against this caravan going
through Tijuana and affecting your
you're probably a trump supporter that's
that's that I'm like so simple I can't
even vote up here yet don't have to be a
full citizen to vote so that it doesn't
even factor in oh god damn it's so crazy
what else about America bothers you I
think you know there's there's
definitely this tendency in America that
I see
the youth in america like i like i have
i have a weird mental comparison of
seeing my nephews down there playing
soccer going out and getting into
trouble going to [ __ ] fights which is
probably pretty dangerous but they go to
[ __ ] fight stuff like that and I see
kids up here on their tablet you know
playing games video games getting
offended by something you know down
there you can still punch somebody in
the face if they get into your face in
school I'll be allowed to do that in
school I mean you're gonna be some
issues but it's fine you know you know
there's there's still that you know up
here it's gone all that's gone you're
gonna get into some issues is probably
gonna get you out of school or something
you know you see this weird puss if
ocation of american children safe spaces
yeah don't say that that's politically
correct classification it's a good word
for it what's the play come up with a
politically correct word for that that
has just as much kick and I'll use that
no they can't it doesn't exist it it's
the pacification yeah I mean and when I
came up here the first year I was up
here I saw the California gun laws
change like I got to see the weird
California compliant rifles come to the
range and you have to push a button to
release the magazine mm-hmm yeah and
make it more difficult to reload yeah so
strange well I mean if if I've never
seen a California compliant gun in the
hands of a criminal myself right so why
why are they good like the good citizens
following the law yeah the idea that you
just can't really cap law-abiding
citizen citizens and that's gonna
somehow or another save lives in mass
shootings and here's the other thing
about you and I'm waiting for this to
happen but it's just not happening
they're never addressing people using
psychotropic drugs they're not they
don't address that all those school
shooters all those mass shooters are all
on drugs yeah they're all on some kind
of psyched drugs and there's there's no
mention of it whatsoever like what what
is the action of these things it's all
about the guns yeah and the guns are a
huge issue means
these people who are [ __ ] up yeah that
they have access and they can get access
to these guns and they can wind up
shooting people yes that is one issue
securities another issue there's another
issue and that's mental health and this
that to me is the biggest one because
without the mental health issue you
don't get mass shooters and that's a
interesting thing we wouldn't I get
people and conversations about the
violence in Mexico and proper
perspective Mexico cartel guys you know
go into a town shoot up a bunch of
people and it's pretty horrible but on
the Mexican side we only had one school
shooting that like a notable one right
and it was mentally ill kid yeah took a
gun to school right and our as Mexicans
we look at what happens in the US and
schools and we're horrified by that's
like completely you know horrific
I'm not amazing it's again being on both
sides I'm just trying to figure things
what about pharmaceuticals being
prescribed to children in Mexico is it
similar not at all not I mean we're so
behind in some and some instances as far
as you know there I didn't know about
PTSD so I came up here or TBI right
really yeah I didn't know anything about
that when did you learn about TBI I when
I started talking truck we should say
what that is post-traumatic stress
disorder and traumatic brain injury yeah
for people well I learned about kids I
learned about it from talking to most of
my marine friends that were coming back
from there like he had like what you're
describing that you're feeling sounds
like TBI really yeah you should get
yourself checked out and then you go
down there and I was like I you know
things would happen and people would get
you know yeah it's just straight get a
few days off take a few shots of tequila
you're fine yeah get back at it
well that's the old school mentality man
that's what they had to deal with in
World War two and Vietnam and yeah yeah
but you yep yeah I mean when it comes to
that but mental health down in Mexico
there's like it's not it's not anywhere
as far as medicating it kids being
diagnosed with things like office when
autism is a thing that I only recently
kind of heard about and 15 years ago in
Mexico and Mexico and what about
antipsychotic drugs and all these
different drugs that you're seeing that
these a lot of these school shooters are
taking in Mexico that's not a thing you
know people think that it's pretty
permissive in Mexico they can get any
drug if you pay somebody off
the thing is that a lot of these
psychiatric level they're they're not
they're not available down there were
people that you can go to they're like
what do you want no this is not
available here so it's not a part of the
culture it's not a mark now no yeah in
America it's such a huge part of the
culture that people want the people are
constantly wanting to take something to
take the edge off or take something so
they could feel better or take something
to you know to just just to alter their
state and the doctor prescribed it to
them and then the pharmaceutical drug
companies are just raking in the cash
from it so it just becomes a part of
reality
yeah there's there was a few people like
way back when I first started you know
things were pretty laxed when I got in
you know they would get you know urine
tested for cocaine and whatever but some
people would go to Oaxaca and go on
mushroom trips like some of the veteran
guys that would go through whatever
there's a there's a place in Oaxaca and
in Veracruz where they'd go up into the
hills and get some of those but they
call them Belarus which is like
basically going to midnight and they
would smoke these mushrooms and take
them and they would come back apparently
fix someone that was like this story
mm-hmm
it was pretty good for them to work
their things out well John Hopkins is
there doing Studies on psilocybin and
there's been studies done in psilocybin
with troops with PTSD and then they've
found that that it does help them MDMA
is another one that Maps is doing all
these studies with MDMA and troops
coming back with PTSD yeah I mean a lot
of this stuff has been around for a long
time down there yeah like remember the
Beatles and members of The Doors went
down there - yep - Edina and they found
out about it was a Life magazine article
from the 1950s that was one of the first
really mainstream gyms here if you find
who wrote that it was a life article in
the 50s I'm trying to remember that the
guy's name
Wasserman Wasserman I feel like it's
Wasserman who was one of the very first
guys to sort of mainstream psilocybin
mushrooms and it was because of Mexican
tribal cultures Maria Vina was like the
the figurehead of that movement she was
a lady that would do these mushroom
trips for people that would come up in
the hillside whether she would take her
was it Gordon Watson I was close yeah it
was something like that
Gordon Watson that's right yeah so this
was seeking the magic mushroom and I
believe this was what year was this
cherry I think it's in the 50s I typed
in 1950 at 57 okay Vina left a whole
legacy of that in Mexico and she had a
lot of people that learn from her and a
lot of these people are all over Mexico
doing you know healing and spiritual
work well that's the other thing about
Mexico Mexico has some you have some
freedom like my friend Edie Edie clay he
had a ibogaine retreat down there where
people would go to get off the pills
yeah because it's one of the iboga
is one of the best ways to get off of
particularly opiates yeah there's you
know there's this enforcement is hard in
a country like Mexico so you're not
gonna have people trying to go inspect
things and run these parts so that's why
there's a lot of places like that you
still to this day you can go to places
where Hawkeye where technically that's
taking mushrooms illegal but they go on
the hillsides it didn't they kind of
like decriminalize a lot of different
things down there for personal use so
the quantities now matter more than they
used to so sometimes you would get
caught with a certain quantity of
something and that means you're selling
it so how many grams of mushrooms can
you have
I have I would have looked up but
everybody has a different opinion on
what personal uses I mean I remember the
first time I saw like a bucks a box of
them and I'm like a load of these and
you know later on I figured out what
they were and you know they were a thing
they're a thing in Mexico there's their
big thing in Mexico hmm
there's a lot of people grown they're a
big thing to anyone who finds out about
them to eat them they become a big thing
yeah yeah apparently I think they use
them in rituals and all sorts of weird
rituals down there as a doorway type
done element like there's a there's a
ritual where they do with where they
bury you alive in a shallow grave oh
Jesus yeah it's pretty basically an
isolation chamber love really poor man's
isolation chamber they bury you alive in
the shell grave with a rope with a bell
on it and they give you a bunch of
mushrooms so you can think about things
in there and if you freak out you ring
that bell you know they dig you out yeah
Oh God yeah how you breathing down there
they go to percents a shallow grave it's
just basically you know about that much
dirt there's a hole where the rub goes
through your so you're gonna fine but
it's a it's a part of the death cult
down there they do that to kind of
initiate people into it but it's it's
mushrooms late they take mushrooms
there's a bunch of weird stuff that goes
down down there as far as the the the
the use of psychotropics like mushrooms
and other things to put people in them
and that mindset of you know accepting a
very specific deity or truth out there
mm-hmm
yeah so let's get back to what's [ __ ]
up about America I always liked talking
to people that are here from somewhere
else and just sort of look at it with a
fresh eye because obviously I've been
here my whole life I'm I'm used to it
yeah and I'm third generation oh you are
yeah okay my parents were second
generation my grandparents came over
here so it's all I'm ingrained you know
I'm in the system I don't know I'm blind
what else is [ __ ] up about this place
I mean I don't know I mean I when I
travel around I get to see different
parts of America and all of them you
know there's there's certain certain
places I've been called
ah you're you're you're one of the good
Mexicans at good ones
I won't say what those parts of the
country are but I've gotten some of that
you know well you the United States is
almost like Europe where like there's
all these different countries except
they all speak the same language yeah
you know like Europe has France and they
have Germany and you go over there
there's this one then the Sweden and
then it's all in this [ __ ] big
landmass yeah but the United States is
landmass is continuous and they all
speak the same language but you want to
tell me that Montana's the same as
Florida you're out of your [ __ ] mind
well I take those comments in stride you
know that you're one of the good
Mexicans I mean being racist and of
racial like that and just messing with
each other is it think Mexicans do that
all the time right so I take it in
stride it's fascinating to me that
people are second-generation Mexicans up
here take more offense to something like
that and then I would somebody say
you're one of the good next week yeah
yeah yeah whatever you know it's it to
me it's like a thing I I take it well
the easier things get the more people
get quickly offended yeah yeah yeah hard
times produce hard men or hard men
produce soft times soft times produce
weak men yeah so when I come up here I
see some you know softness and a lot of
the society and a lot of feelings get
hurt having to watch what I say as far
as you know I was yeah I was tell this
to people
first off I'm from Mexico I come from a
Mexican education system it's a third
world country so please take everything
I say with that in mind right and then I
go into whatever I'm gonna say and like
when you do like when you teach class
when I have a class where I have a like
I just recently did a conference with a
bunch of bodyguards and security
professionals that work internationally
I had to start with that one just to not
offend anybody you know that's hilarious
you're teaching security guards and
bodyguards and you have to worry about
being offended every now and then you
get somebody you know what you said
something oh Christ you [ __ ] babies
yeah so never read the comment section
never never stay behind and talk to
people especially if they they look like
they're they want to speak to the
manager you know oh did you get that you
teach class and right now and then I
guess what did they say - yeah you know
I think yeah I think your point of view
is is a skewed because you work for the
government down there and you weren't
part of the like the poor class and like
I'm losing part of the pork loss if you
work for like where I worked when we
were pretty poor pretty / poor right
it's not like you know what's the middle
class it was pretty poor or or they or
they try to tell me the realities of
where I'm from oh that must be hilarious
oh that's pretty good that's pretty good
Edie you're just fear-mongering about
Mexico I go down to Rosarito all the
time with my family it's fine
while Rosarito fine go downtown we'll
leave us where the shooting happened and
tell me the same thing you know it's
perspective they really say that to you
I can't imagine someone talk
particularly talking to someone like you
yeah who's got like real-world
experience there's there's people out
there that kind of I believe you yeah I
mean I do people are so [ __ ] dumb I
do believe you yeah yeah but it is
really true that it's the the people
that live the softest easiest lives that
are most offended and the people that
have experienced like real hardship and
seen real violence that are a little
more hesitant to comment on things like
that
oh yeah that's that is possible yeah
that is real yeah and and that's one of
the other things that I really think is
good about your page and it really makes
me angry that Instagram censors it is
that you're giving real world
perspective you're showing real video of
a lot of this stuff and you put it up
with with also your educated experience
on what these people are actually
involved in yeah and and it's a I'm not
involved in a news agency and a lot of
this like both of those videos came in
through direct messenger to my phone
from people that are out there and this
is happening here like okay mmm you talk
about it okay I'll talk about it but
when the Mormon thing happened the
people the people that reach out to me
to talk about it were part of the family
and was real and it wasn't national news
when I posted it up
all right so the some of the first like
social media post about it that I could
kind of try and look for it and it was
wasn't anywhere so I talked about it and
like that that evening it went national
news and but most of it is directly from
having connections and people out there
that still talk to me keep my ear open
to that type of stuff specifically from
that region because that's that's my
thing that's where I came from well
there's not a lot of mainstream news
that's dedicated to this crisis
dedicated to what's going on it just it
takes a big event like that to sort of
break through all the noise and become a
signal it reaches us over here yeah yeah
and it's you know again and things
happen somewhere else and now all the
attention that most people aren't
focused on Iran now yeah the whole what
happened down there there yeah it's just
[ __ ] crazy okay there's a giant
problem right next door you could walk
to it literally I mean if you live in
San Diego it's a fifteen minute drive
yeah yeah like it's right there well
it's just to me it's I love San Diego
and I love going down there but every
time I go down there I'm like you guys
could walk to Mexico like this is so
crazy like especially La Jolla yeah La
Jolla which is one of the most richest
parts of the country [ __ ]
unbelievably beautiful
there's stunning views gorgeous mansions
everybody's driving a Mercedes you're 15
minutes away from Tijuana yeah and if we
have heavy rains in Tijuana all of our
sewage is gonna go right through there
really yes that what happens a lot of
the soot like recently we have major
major rain in Tijuana all the sewage
goes across the border to a Tijuana
estuary there's a there's a processing
facility the US has on this side but it
can't manage all that and they have to
close all the beaches in the air oh wow
which is again it's fascinating how to
see how the effect there's a boy there's
a poor wall there but are you getting a
boat you grow over there
it takes three minutes oh you can
parkour yeah I recently posted up a
bunch of videos of people park chorong
over that wall I saw it yeah look I
admire ingenuity
I admire people that find solutions to
problems watching that guy scale that
goddamn wall like Batman
yeah
it's amazing yeah they're coming up with
weird ways like I saw some people using
powdered titanium to to melt the bars on
on one of the slats
how did titanium again I had to research
it basically it's a powder titanium
Prince at a very high rate and when you
start it it's kind of hard to put it out
so they might hold on and this wall
would powder that with some sort of
powder titanium mix that's like that
[ __ ] what was that [ __ ] that they were
talking about with 911 where all the
conspiracy theorists thought that it
melted steel goddamn it pyrite tanner
something like that right or just talk
to my head oh yeah that's the one yeah I
feel like that's the stuff they blow
[ __ ] up with right now they sell these
things they call breach bends like and
they there's there's the four tactical
applications of these pens that B sticks
that you start and you can burn chains
open stuff like that with them really
yeah so basically a ghetto version of
that is what they're using you know in
some of these places I know the the I
mean the the wall as they're making it
and speaking to some of the Border
Patrol agents that I that I know it does
it job at as far as slowing people down
yeah so there's not an overflow of
people coming yeah it's not like what
would happen if it was that that's all
night Banzai yeah what would happen if
everybody if there was no border
everybody's like five Mexico's United
States nights is Mexico have a good time
yeah it would be chaotic of course how
long ten years I don't know how long I
mean once everybody got in yeah other
people go there yeah I mean if what if
United States and Mexico came to a deal
and they said yeah well call wasn't
there a thing that they were gonna do
there was a North American agreement
there was like they were trying to do
that with the United States and set up a
single currency yes yeah that's a lot of
conspiracy theories around the Amero
yeah that's something like that look
they were gonna do it with Canada we're
all gonna be coming you see I could see
like Canada yeah but maybe not you know
Mexico well look we could all spread all
the good around yeah and then also like
look Mexico's got some awesome spots
wouldn't be great if US industry moved
in there and with you yes
maybe that's gonna hold with you well
Colombia did a great job in eradicating
all the the problems with narcotics I
think it is with well not all because it
still have a gorilla gorilla group down
there that recently the FARC that went
amnesty and then they got active again
but they're still there's still a lot of
cocaine being produced there oh yeah
yeah but it's not nothing like when
there's no no what did they do well they
were facing just just a few criminal
groups large ones and Mexico is facing a
lot of them that's interesting they have
the u.s. right next door that is pumping
money into the issue directly didn't
have to fly in no yeah it's not a long
plane flight it's a short walk I also
Mexico is a pretty big country I think
people kind of missed that also it's a
pretty big pretty big country do you
remember when there was a CIA drug plane
that had like several tons of cocaine on
it and it crashed cuz the Mexican
government wouldn't let them land and
refuel yeah yeah I mean all sorts of
conspiracy theories that was a real CIA
drug plane that had been to Guantanamo
Bay at least twice yeah like it was
documented yeah and they for whatever
reason I mean I flying back with a lot
of coke look at that coke
I imagine imagine government groups
everywhere have a voice yeah yeah you
have Cowboys when people try to say the
CIA brings in drugs no no people who
work for the CIA realize they can make a
shitload of money if they bring in drugs
and they pass that money around and they
work it out but the CIA itself does not
bring in drugs yeah
customers Customs and Border Protection
agent agent sand just Homeland Security
as an agency has the most corruption
charges as far as all law enforcement
agencies is it really you have federal
federal charges for corruption because
they are on border and money other were
of course that's that's why right it
totally makes sense and you know I mean
it maybe it was a CIA guy that said you
know could make some money through here
well I mean that was the whole Barry
seals thing that Tom Cruise movie I mean
it was it called made in America I think
I made in America that was about
bringing in drugs with the with Cowboys
that work for the CIA yeah I mean when I
was working down there in New Mexico and
I got to see different agencies that we
would work with all of a sudden were
like hey can you guys just go like look
over there or just were there like
what's going on and you would see like
some sort of you know what's going on
you know but lands plane takes off
nothing nobody saw nothing you know
money exchanges and just you know that's
in Europe just an agent you know she's
in the background well that's the thing
that's so scary about what's going on
with the cartels is that the quantity of
money is so extraordinary yeah it's
almost like they can do anything yeah I
mean they have their own cell phone
networks in some places what yeah called
that we good if I knew but their kind of
coverage they have pretty good coverage
in their areas I mean they dismantled
some cell phone networks in the past
also like whole cities with hidden
cameras that are cartel controlled to
see who kills in and out of the of the
towns Wow like so sophisticated oh yeah
so the Mexicans Mexican government is
working with uniformed agents patrolling
and pickup trucks in the back and these
guys are living in 2025 and using drones
to to surveil the the patrols in the
area and they're using their own cell
phone network so they don't have to
worry worried about government tapping
into their communications they're
utilizing encrypted phone technology
that is available now commercially
throughout the world to get around some
of these things and and they're in there
working they're constantly evolving and
how they work you know I remember the
first time I was working in Baja and all
the cartel guys were we move around in
suburban stressed like federal agents
and they would look exactly like the
legit federal agents or there were
federal agents with the cartel guys
so you would oh my god so they'd be
together yeah and then we started
working with the military and the
military didn't give a [ __ ] who you were
so I would stop everybody she would
everybody
and the guys immediately saying so now
we're using taxicabs to move around and
different types of cars and we're gonna
paint the the the vans like taxi vans or
we're gonna move around in ambulances so
they change their tactics so we were
always after these convoys of Suburbans
and now they're doing something else so
that's how they evolved they just you
know you're trying to go after it with a
hammer and these guys are mosquitos does
it make you want to move to Canada
furthest you can get away from all the
game you know yeah must be going on up
there as well right they know suburbs so
I interviewed a smuggler a coyote for
one of the articles I wrote and he you
know asked him directly like what do you
think about the the border wall and the
immigration policies of this current
administration it's good for business
you know it makes it seem like it's
harder to put people in the United
States so I mean that wall is pretty
hard like how would you do it I fly them
to Canada and they walk down well we
talked about it before that the border
the United States is a wall to Mexico
the border from the United States to
Canada is a giant clearing that's a
hundred yards wide it's real clear you
can see it's almost like they make it
easy hey just go right here
yeah I mean a lot of people that want to
get to the into u.s. here you hear
numbers from $8,000 to $15,000 depending
on who you are what you're trying to do
how you're trying to get up here as far
as being smuggled up and he's like past
Mexican Passport
get a Mexican passport if you're Mexican
we'll get you a Mexican Passport
we'll put two thousand dollars in an
account somewhere so if they want to
verify if you're just financially
solvent they will check that and just
fly to Canada and just walk down and
that's what we do well can a super
liberal now to it Justin Trudeau guys
that's a lot of a lot of there a lot of
their business as far as among people
that's how they do it right now instead
of going through the desert you know
there is that there is a lot of that
going on now to like some there's a lot
of people moved from Africa Africa not
migrants coming into into Mexico people
Middle East as well which is worrying
for some people coming in through Mexico
trying to make their way up but it's
pretty hard for these people now because
there's a lot of security now on both
sides of the border Mexican why didn't
as you're now and on this side of the
border things are kind of more stringent
a lot of the people that claim the
Siloam like a lot of the neck my Caravan
members coming to the u.s. claiming
asylum and say okay there's your number
to wait but you're gonna wait in Mexico
so they get sent back even if they're
not from Mexico they we have to wait in
Mexico it's very interesting yeah
there's a lot of these immigrant waiting
encampments and places like Texas and
even Tijuana
it's places where people get cross
Asylum okay here's your number you don't
have to wait in Mexico they get sent
back oh yeah man are you hopeful things
is gonna work out okay when you mean
this okay this is what we're all talking
about yeah that's gonna become better a
better situation in the future or is it
gonna get more and more crazy is the
United States gonna become like Mexico I
think at a global scale we're gonna need
each other before before you know before
too long you know you guys are gonna
need Mexico and Mexico is gonna need you
there's gonna be some sort of situation
we're gonna have to come together
probably you mean like a global war I
don't know could be oh jesus said I mean
there's a lot I mean there's a lot of
Chinese influences and in industry in
Mexico yes as soon as Trump said we're
gonna when he when Trump was going in to
put into office he said we're gonna
bring jobs back you know this whole
thing so a lot of factories American
factories and businesses moved out of
Mexico and the Chinese moved in
absolutely well that's what's dumb about
shortsightedness right yeah well not
understanding for deep three dimensional
chess you know there's a lot of moving
pieces yeah and and and you know people
can say whatever they want about the
United States American companies and
Mexico are pretty good companies and
they're pretty good
their workers and their ethics are
pretty good a lot better than China a
lot better than China you know it's a
it's a different it's a different game
and you know it's it's again you see
these influences going into Mexico
because they realize that Mexico is a
valuable place for them to have
influence in especially with what you're
talking about with lithium I mean what I
mean with battery technology and green
technology becoming in the forefront of
American culture right now I mean
everybody wants electric cars all these
manufacturers Ford Mercedes they're all
coming out with electric cars Porsche is
gonna electric car now yeah I mean
that's a big deal yeah and those
batteries yeah that's the next you know
that's the next oil quick that oil type
situation is going to be lithium and
that's right next door all right so I
think again I think as a second largest
consumer of American products in the
world is Mexico second largest so
economies are intertwined they have a
lot of Americans living down there
there's a lot of blood ties to within
the country of course Americans don't
want America to be Mexico and of course
a lot of Mexicans want Mexico to be more
like America that's what would fix
things increasing the opportunities and
making Mexico a better place yeah we
need to make some make Mexico great
again shirts and yeah and get getting
fights at the airport really if we're
connected to Mexico if Mexico was like
Canada where you know like Canada is
[ __ ] wonderful you go over there
there's amazing cities it's it's great
it's safe it's clean if we can make
Mexico like that then we'd have you know
it would be better for everybody
including Mexico including the United
States everybody post-911 at the border
you could see how businesses started
failing in San Diego because it became
harder to cross the border mmm so you
interested since there's there's
symbiotic relationship with some of
these border towns specifically
California is very dependent on some
port towns in Mexico yeah we were sent
three a day without Mexicans yeah shut
this whole [ __ ] place down man
there's nothing going on without
Mexicans here yeah that's why
anti-mexican racism some of the dumbest
racism in all of the united states but
particularly for California it's so
stupid I you know I got to see how like
in places like Fallbrook California
where the the avocado capital of the
world cutting down all the avocado trees
because there's a drought and there's
nobody to pick them really yeah there's
less no one to pick less people coming
up and it's harder to maintain like
don't people they hire illegals and
there's holy [ __ ] these farms need to
organize start working on border control
it's like the whole I don't know man i
i'm i'm one of those people that
believes in borders but I also believe
if you're a hard-working person who
wants to do better you should have an
opportunity and and I don't think a lot
of people particularly poor people that
aren't very well educated there's not an
opportunity you can't there's no reason
for them to be over here so if they
apply for United States Citizenship
well there's well why you want to come
here well I want to come here for
opportunity what do you have to offer
I'm you know I'm a hard worker there's a
lot of hard workers I mean that's really
the attitude yeah you know and I think
we all just got I mean me I got lucky I
got lucky my grandparents came here
dad got lucky that's all it is it's just
luck and to deny that and to deny these
other people this opportunity this just
got to be a way to filter out bad people
yeah maybe as technology gets better we
could recognize bad people better yeah I
mean I went through a bunch of
questioning they look at my background I
got a lot of questions before I show you
right I got a looks and it's fine you
know and I you know I was like I didn't
you know I didn't do anything wrong so
I'm like I'm here it's fine but you know
there's a lot of people like again
the Luna Garcia Luna was here on a green
card and he got nabbed when he went to
process his full citizenship so he was
here for a long time Wow
he should just stuck with the green card
I would have kept quiet for a layer
that's he's in jail right he lied to a
to an immigration agent
that's one of the charges he has on Wow
right so it's pretty interesting that
people like him have spent a long time
of year things like open secrets and you
know yeah I mean again not all not all
Mexicans good good guys you know not all
humans are good yeah I know yeah so you
know hardworking people come up here I
got some of the people that that I've
met out here that are kind of on the
same boat as I am fresh in the country
you know doing manual labor construction
working at Kentucky ice I met a bunch of
guys that were working on the Kentucky
Derby or the horse stalls around them
all Mexicans you could smell you know
the tortillas the good food is usually
you can smell you know you can you know
where they are
dude there's a place if you're hungry
there's a place I don't tell anybody the
name because I don't want to [ __ ] it up
okay and I place down the street from
here that like everywhere time you go in
there Mexican soap operas playing nobody
speaks English the food's off the charts
lengua tacos oh yeah language adieus
yeah make Oregon meet great again yeah
that's another so I'm talking about
yeah working more organ means don't
throw away the tongue tripe yeah tripe -
I love liver
I eat heart and liver that's another
thing weird thing I see all the stuff
you throw away from the I know they've
never had menudo oh that's that's that
this place up here house menudo oh it's
off the charts
bet best hangover food and the new the
new dough and right well how does it
work there's like a science behind that
you know organ meat I don't know there's
a lot of nutrients in it basically a lot
of nutrients get stored in an organ it's
a soup so you get the rehydration from
that yeah and it's like a common thing
in Mexico about liver specifically
mm-hmm
I grew up on a pig in a pig farm and my
mom would have this rule if you killed
it you have to eat it so kill the
rattlesnake once and I was peeling it
and the liver over the rattlesnake was
like a treat that she would give us
right really yeah raw raw whoo yeah it's
a core well my mom was pretty hard
okay sounds slow yeah but listen man
thanks for coming here and dropping
knowledge we really appreciate you and
again edie manifesto is your Instagram
page yeah its manifesto please everybody
sign up go follow him check it out get
yourself educated find out what's going
on and tell Instagram to go [ __ ]
themselves what they're doing is rude
does it yeah
thanks brother appreciate you man thank
you bye everybody
[Music]
[Applause]